Здається, це було вічність тому.
Насправді ж не минуло й року, відколи Анґела Меркель та її партія
перемогли на виборах у Німеччині - вчетверте поспіль.
Однак відтоді Меркель опинилася у певній ізоляції -
причому не через нападки опозиції, а через втрату найближчих соратників.
Вони виступають проти ліберальної політики Меркель щодо біженців.
Поштовх до спротиву зумовив цей чоловік - Горст Зеегофер,
голова баварського Християнсько-соціального союзу,
сестринської партії  консервативної ХДС на чолі з Меркель.
У березні канцлерка призначила Зеегофера міністром внутрішніх справ,
натомість він скористався своїм постом,
аби підірвати авторитет Меркель.
Розкол почався ще у 2015 році,
коли Німеччина відчула масивну хвилю біженців.
Зрештою до ФРН прибули майже мільйон шукачів притулку
з таких країн,  як Сирія й Ірак,
а також з Балканськиого півострова та Північної Африки.
Багато хто вбачав у німецькій канцлерці рятівницю знедолених.
Тоді ж Меркель зробила заяву,
яка стала визначальною для її уряду.
Ми так багато досягли, ми впораємося з цим.
Відтоді ставлення до Анґели Меркель стало двояким.
Світ вважає її найвпливовішою жінкою світу,
близькою до тодішнього президента США Барака Обами,
на яку орієнтуються інші світові лідери.
Однак зовсім інакше на Меркель дивляться у її власній країні.
Багаторічна німецька канцлерка вчергове очолює велику коаліцію,
якої мало хто хотів.
На тлі зростання напруги в уряді ера канцлерства Меркель
може добігти кінця, якщо їй не вдасться
примирити ХДС та ХСС.
Від самого початку кризи біженців ХСС
чинив опір політиці відкритих кордонів Меркель.
Лідери сестринських партій часто сперечалися з цього приводу,
як-от на з'їзді ХСС у листопаді 2015-го.
Ми абсолютно переконані,
що це велике історичне завдання -
інтеграція біженців у нашій країні -
не матиме в перспективі підтримки населення,
якщо ми не встановимо вищу межу дозволеного прийому біженців.
Таку вимогу Меркель прийняти не могла,
тож розкол між партіями ставав
дедалі відчутнішим і очевидним.
Якщо так триватиме далі, цьогоріч ми матимемо більше біженців, ніж торік.
Немає жодної координації,
немає плану дій уряду в Берліні.
Як би там не було, без обмеження
і вищої межі для притоку мігрантів не обійтися.
Я може лише ще раз сказати: система обрушується.
Зрештою подальшому перебуванню Меркель на посаді
загрожує внутрішня політика.
Притік біженців зумовив у ФРН підйом
правопопулістської партії "Альтернатива для Німеччини",
яка нині є справжньою загрозою для ХСС
на майбутніх земельних виборах у Баварії.
Саме тому ХСС погрожує порвати зв'язки з Меркель та її ХДС,
припинивши партнерство,
яке тривало з часів завершення Другої світової війни.
Ця політична битва може остаточно покласти край
13-річному правлінню Анґели Меркель.